imagine if you had access to a property
millionaire that could answer all your
questions every single week well guess
what i've got some good news for you
that's exactly what you've got right
here on the samuel leeds youtube channel
[Music]
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds in
this video i'm going to be answering
your questions around property
investment so usually if you're not
getting the results that you want in
property if you're not financially free
if you're not a property millionaire
there's it's because of something that
you don't know so think about it imagine
if you had access to a property
millionaire that could answer all your
questions every single week well guess
what i've got some good news for you
that's exactly what you've got right
here on the samuel leeds youtube channel
so you want to be successful all you
need to do number one is you need to
subscribe to the channel number two you
need to smash the like button and then
number three you need to comment and ask
your questions below and i will answer
them on the next q a sunday video and
while you're liking and while you're
commenting i'm going to be answering
some of last week's questions so sam
bigerstaff
says should i do a few rent to rent to
get me started before going legal in
deal sourcing what would your best
advice be
so sam great question so it sounds to me
like you've not got any money
which is cool there ain't no problem
with having no money as long as you're
learning the skills and you're doing
something about it so you've got no
money and you're saying should i get a
few rent to rent
to get me started and then put that
money into becoming a compliant deal
sourcer
i may have misunderstood the question
but if that's what you've asked i
probably would say no don't do that
that's the worst thing you could do and
i'll tell you why because it costs money
to get a rent to rent you're going to
need a deposit you're going to need some
contracts you're going to need rent to
the landlord
so if you've not got much money and
you're thinking maybe i'll do rent to
rent and get some money and then put
that into becoming a compliant deal
sourcer
i wouldn't do that what i would do is
this i would i would find somebody
who's already a deal sourcer who's
already compliant who's already got
their company established who's already
up and running with investors
these people are everywhere because i
train them i train thousands of people
to become successful deal sources and i
would say to them i'd literally just say
hey
what are your investors looking for
right now
oh they're looking for hmos in
birmingham oh they're looking for this
this this if i can find a really good
deal for you to pass to your investors
would you give me a percentage of the
fee and let's say they say yeah i'll
give you 50
or even 25
the average deal sells for 3 000 pounds
you sell one or two deals like that
then you can become compliant yourself
you can start advertising marketing the
best and quickest way to get in money
from property is through deal sourcing
quick cash and then once you've got a
bit of cash put that into
rental reps that's my advice hope that
helps all right next question victor
jose monterey or tears says quick
question who usually pays the council
tax in a rent to rent and rent to
service accommodation deal
great question super important you know
this stuff so that you can budget and
you can forecast your your deals so the
council tax is usually paid by the
person living in the house okay so
firstly what is council tax council tax
is a sum of money it's fixed you can
find out what it is by just googling the
area the postcode you can find out what
what council tax band it's in and it
will tell you how much you're gonna have
to pay it's a monthly amount of money
you paid to the local council which just
covers things like your wheelie bins and
you know stuff like that so usually
speaking the tenant the person living in
the property will pay the council tax
if the property is empty
then the owner of the property will pay
the council tax if you're doing a rent
to rent
namely you're renting it from the
landlord and then you're putting tenants
in then it depends on the types of
tenants the landlord probably isn't
going to pay it the landlord actually is
never going to pay it
the council taxes are either going to be
paid by you
or by the person living in the property
now if the person living in the property
or the people living in the property are
on service accommodation if they're like
guests that are in and out then they're
not going to pay the council tax because
they're in and out they're just going to
pay you a supreme
super high
rate of being there which is going to
obviously contribute towards all the
costs and also your profit so to answer
your question if the property is a rent
to serviced accommodation generally
speaking the council tax is going to be
paid by
you that helps
all right next mr s
mr s says i've watched you for years and
have been to your free training
although my question is if there's some
people that have been on your academy
and have had one-to-one training with
you why are they not financially free
that's a great question mr s um
generally speaking people that do my
mentoring my advanced training
the vast majority of them do go on to
achieve financial freedom do you go on
to achieve a lot of success and we we
have you know i i hold myself
accountable i have independent surveyors
that come in and do a whole independent
surveys with all of my advanced students
does that mean that every single person
that ever pays for a course or does
mentoring with me every single one of
them has the ultimate success and has
ultimate financial freedom not every
single one does and you know i try my
best you know on the academy for
instance we have mentoring coaching they
have invitations to come to my house we
have very very very advanced accelerated
coaching training and mentoring and as a
result we have a we i think we probably
have the highest success rate in the
entire country probably in the entire
planet of people that come through and
people who succeed
but no not every single person succeeds
and um it breaks my heart when it
happens it does happen occasionally but
the vast majority do so i hope that
helps
all right luke walker
myself and a business partner are
wanting to get into property investment
within one to two years time we want to
eventually make it our only source of
income what would you suggest the best
course of action is to take within
different types of property that can be
invested in and the minimum sort of
funding needed for getting the ball
rolling
okay so what i'd probably say luke is
you say your business partner depends on
how your business is going at the moment
if you're you and your business partner
right now
are making
decent money in whatever business you're
in
i would probably suggest that you focus
most of your time in that business
because if that business is working if
it's successful if it's making good
profits
then you'd be silly to then be like oh
let me try and do a bit of deal sourcing
and try and do a rent to rent and let me
also try and do
this and this and you know what i focus
down
so i wouldn't try and do the strategies
that are entrepreneurial within property
i wouldn't try and set up a property
trading business
i'd focus on your actual business now
the profits that you make from your
business i would put them aside and i
would then invest them into property but
that's going to be passive okay you're
going to just be investing them into buy
refurbished refinance you're going to be
paying a team to do but that's going to
be passive then you've got your active
income from your business and then
you've got your passive income from your
property and the idea will be that over
the years that the property business
would replace the passive income would
replace the active income in your
business so you've got complete
financial security and stability now if
your current business is not making very
much money if you're struggling if
you're struggling to make ends meet then
i would probably consider
scrapping that business and going full
time into the property business which
would involve very little money because
you're going to be using strategies like
deal sourcing and rentals all these
strategies which are very very lucrative
but do take time you've got to roll your
sleeves up so that's generally my advice
i'd love to get to know you a little bit
more so i can give you more bespoke
advice i hope to meet you if you want to
meet me at one of the training days on
the house
tickets in the description okay so hope
to see you soon
all right few more questions we've got
john robinson
i was wondering if you have any
experience with purchasing council
properties on behalf of the current
tenants
my grandparents can get their house a
very low price but are too old for a
mortgage i'd like to help
josh that is a great question
it's something that i've thought about
for many hours
i've considered i've toyed with i've met
a lot of people in a similar situation
as your grandparents
but i've never done it so i can't really
give you advice on this apart from to
say
i hope you find a way and if you find a
way message my instagram and let me know
because basically your grandparents
because they own the property and
they've lived there for years they've
got the right to buy at a huge discount
but if they can't afford to buy but
they've got this opportunity of a
discount what can you do i was thinking
about doing like a lease option so
saying look you all loan you the money
you buy it and then i'll have the option
to buy it back but it never happened in
the end it fell through and um let me
know if you come up with a creative way
because i know a lot of people that got
right to buy they ain't got the money so
let me know
all right raz van gabriel
i'm about to buy my first house on a
residential mortgage and my lender is
happy with me moving two lodges in there
my question is can i get those two
lodges on short stays from airbnb
booking.com thanks um as long as there's
nothing in your contract that says that
you can't have short stay legs if if if
the lender is happy for you to rent out
the rooms and have lodges
i can't see what would be an issue but
it really depends on what the terms are
of your mortgage maybe ask the question
or you could just try and get
forgiveness sometimes i say that
forgiveness is better than permission um
so
read the contract and just see if he
says anything about shortlists but the
fact that you can get two lodges in is
amazing and you don't pay tax up to the
first seven and a half thousand pounds
because you get bedroom relief tax so
sounds to me like either way you're onto
a bit of a winner there so great stuff
last question
nick malvon
i know you say it's better to rent a
property than to own one as your own
home
my question is you already if you
already own your own home should you
rent it out and rent another property
can you help with this thanks
um nick great question man great great
question so if you already own a house
then i would probably consider three
options
um option number one i i don't think i'd
rent the house out and then go and rent
somewhere else i don't think that's
gonna
really achieve much i might consider
number one i might consider selling the
house
and then with the profits
investing that into multiple properties
and then with the rental income that
you're making from all these properties
rent your home that would be a good
option option number two is i might
consider staying in the house and if
there's equity in the home refinancing
and releasing some of those phones from
the house and then staying in the house
getting a higher mortgage but then using
the equity to buy multiple homes to rent
out and increase your passive income
cash flow that would be a reasonable
option or option number three if there's
not much equity in the house
and if it's you know you want to help to
buy or it's a house it's a shared
ownership or there's just not much
equity or if you particularly like the
house you could just say you know what
i'm just gonna stay here and then just
stay in the house
and and build up your portfolio the
usual way so those are probably the best
three options and if you're not sure
what to do what i would consider doing
is doing do a case study for each one so
say look if we did decide to sell
what would life look like what would we
buy what would our financial situation
be if we did decide to refinance what do
the figures look like if we decide and
and just do split test each three
examples and work out which one's going
to give you number one the best
financial set of circumstances but
number two lifestyle sometimes people
just like their own home maybe you're
married and if you sold the house your
wife would kill you in which case it's
probably not worth it so i hope that
helps i hope you enjoyed the q a don't
forget
hit like doesn't cost anything because
it's nothing to smash the like button
drop your comment or question below and
i'll be answering next week god bless
[Music]
you